so okay what are you teaching me today
eggs with chickpeas and tomato sauce
i'm gonna do it in five minutes i mean
that's revelatory because that's such a
deterrent
because when they say prep time 20
minutes cook time 60 minutes
it's not realistic for a lot of people's
lives
so listen we have the pan we have the
oil
and you have garlic i have garlic right
here
put the garlic on there in the and now
talk to your garlic
tell a darling how are you how are you
doing baby hey baby
how's it going my kid's grandfather ari
that's what he always says hey baby
the garlic is speaking back to you and
the garlic is telling
you oh i'm so happy i'm cooking with raw
i'm jose it's amazing i love
garlic the more the better okay so in
this moment we put the chickpeas now
roger that this is actually great to buy
a can of chickpeas which are delicious
and usually they have
a very good price on the supermarket i
was going to say i think they're
a very uh healthy thing for people
and you have a vegetable book and for
vegetarians they're a really satisfying
like
protein substitute i love them so you
take a look at the chickpeas
they're so happy because they love to be
with the garlic
people don't know this but chickpeas and
garlic they are very friendly
okay you have to lift up the temperature
put
higher temperature bro oh jose i'm so
excited to tell you
that i just did that that means we're
telepathically linked now i'm in so
in this moment this is very important i
will add a little bit more foil to your
pan i love olive oil
um by the way check this olive oil out
okay hang on beauty shot there we go i
love your olive oil thank you so much
for sending it to us
let's say you have fresh tomatoes you
can get a peeled fresh tomato and cut
it in cubes or
you have canned tomatoes and
also works very well or
you have any pasta tomato sauce that is
already made
everything works just make sure that you
do whatever you have at home
is what you use i think that makes
people less stressed in the kitchen
thank you drew recipes should be like
life itself when you don't have some of
the ingredients
just move on change the recipe in your
dishes or in your life and you'll always
be successful that's a very important
lesson
in cooking and in life
jose look i'm sizzling baby
so now i have a can of spanish pimenton
yes what we call paprika if you have it
if you don't have paprika called chili
flakes if you don't have put
cumin if you don't put whatever spice
you have
in your kitchen make the recipe your own
a paprika i love you so
and now i'm putting the tomato in
because this tomato is already cooked
it's going to be easy i mean i cannot
prove
that i am actually cooking with you
yeah i mean when i told my daughters
they were like
come on daddy don't make fun of us
i'm cooking with her jose how old are
your daughters
i have three uh carlota she's 21.
in s she's 19th and lufia she's 16.
so listen this is very important now
there's tomato sauce
the chickpea everything is cooked and i
am putting inside
four of my pegs in this moment you put
some salt on the eggs
and ladies and gentlemen you cover the
pot
and now you can open a glass of wine you
can open yourself a beer
you can drink a sherry so
why i'm doing this one pot drew because
very often many recipes they require
three or four or five pops you can make
everything with one pot
no cleaning this is great i love one pot
i think
it really helps people feel like they
can
manage if they're not like i'm just not
that girl who's like so betty how was
your day
i'm just stirring and casual i'm like
[Applause]
so one pot for me is you know a great
way to cook that makes that keeps me
calm
this pandemic i've been cooking a lot
with my daughters and we did some
cooking on social media and
quite frankly we were doing it because
it was fun because we were spending so
many hours and we began sharing it with
people
and it was one of the best moments of my
life to be cooking with my three
daughters
already man i remember them first time i
had them
in my arms and i was crying it was after
they came up into the wall
and now 21 years later i realized
through this pandemic
that there are these three grown-up
girls and to me cooking with my
daughters has been the happiest moment
of my life
look at that look at that beauty shot
and now i'm gonna try it
okay yep
oh yeah oh god that's good the great
thing about this dish
is that you can make it your own in so
many ways you can cook it every time
and every time be a different recipe you
can put some mozzarella
you can put some manchego cheese oh
topping it with cheese would like kick
kick it up a whole other level you're
right and don't be afraid of trying new
things
always just take risks they will always
pay off
jose you make the world
a better place and you help us be better
people
with your wisdom
[Music]
you